Bernie Sanders has won the New Hampshire
primary election he narrowly defeated
Pete Buda judge last night they're both
going to end up with the same number of
Delegates nine from New Hampshire we
will have updated total delegate numbers
and much much more coming up a thank you
to the more than hundred thousand or so
different people that caught at least
some piece of last night's results live
stream with me on youtube twitch and
facebook live we had a great time
watching the results developed live took
a bunch of phone calls it was great
let's look at the results and of course
Bernie Sanders jumped to a large lead up
front if you were watching live you saw
Bernie leading by about 12 percentage
points towards the beginning of the
results coming in that lead shrank over
the course of two hours and it got down
to ten and then eight and six and five
four three and then it teetered between
one and a half and three percentage
points ultimately ended with Bernie
Sanders defeating Pete by 1.5 percentage
points with a popular vote victory of
just over 4,200 now because New
Hampshire Awards delegates
proportionately you will notice on
screen that Bernie comes away with nine
delegates and Budaj also comes away with
nine delegates six delegates for Amy
Klobuchar who really was the over
performer of the night exactly as
expected and I want to talk about that a
little bit yesterday in looking at the
polling I predicted that Amy Klobuchar
would be the over performer of the night
because if you looked at her polling
trajectory the polls of course ending a
few days short of the primary in other
words there were polls released
yesterday but they had only interviewed
people up to a couple of days prior and
looking at her trajectory it was
realistic to believe that her surge
continued beyond what the latest polls
reflected not fully representative of
the clamp globish art surge in New
Hampshire and indeed that's what
happened so let's now look at polling
versus actual results to see who over
performed who underperformed and I don't
think you'll find the results to
surprising
as you can see amy klobuchar are over
performing her polling by a massive 8.2
percentage points meanwhile Bernie
Sanders underperformed by 2.8 points
still one Joe Biden underperformed
by 2.6 now interestingly I got a bunch
of emails from people saying David you
know Bernie was the biggest under
performer of the night by two point
eight that's true but Joe Biden's under
performance also involved Joe Biden
finishing fifth right Joe Biden
underperformed and finished fifth and
now again more questions about his
viability in this entire thing come up
Bernie Sanders underperformed by 2.8 but
still ended up winning so there are the
the meaning and significance of those
under performances are quite different
Elizabeth Warren gave a strange sort of
it actually was like a concession speech
but not just about New Hampshire it was
almost like she was conceding the entire
primary to either Pete or Bernie she
kept talking about it's still early
we're gonna fight
but both Bernie and Pete would be great
I'm going to keep fighting but we need
to rally around the eventual nominee
implying she knows it's not going to be
her and interestingly enough Donald
Trump saw it basically the same way
although Trump laced his commentary with
the discriminatory nickname Pocahontas
tweeting last night quote Elizabeth
Warren sometimes referred to as
Pocahontas is having a really bad night
I think she is sending signals that she
wants out calling for unity is her way
of getting there going home and having a
nice cold beer with her husband this is
essentially my analysis although I don't
refer to Elizabeth Warren as Pocahontas
but I did seem like Elizabeth Warren was
starting a sort of wind down also by the
way somebody noticed as a funny aside
looking at Trump's tweets last night
that not only did Trump's analysis of
the Warren's speech match mine Trump
also seems to be adopting my
pronunciation of Pete Buddha jej
tweeting quote boot edge edge
parentheses Buddha
he's doing pretty well tonight giving
crazy Bernie a run for his money very
interesting I would be shocked if Trump
is actually getting that from me that
would definitely be something else so
let's talk delegate totals delegate
totals as of right now as I told you
insignificant in terms of the delegate
math you need 1990 delegates to secure
the nomination all that the current
numbers tell us is that we are starting
to see enough of a split in the delegate
math that if this trajectory continues
no one will get to 1990 and it will be a
contested convention we'll deal with
that in more detail tomorrow but looking
at totals Pete Budaj edge now with 22
delegates he has his 13 from Iowa plus 9
from last night
Bernie Sanders with 21 delegates he has
his 12 from Iowa plus 9 from last night
Warren has 8 Amy 7 and Joe Biden 6
nobody else has any delegates note that
for now Bernie Sanders has won the raw
votes in 100% of the primaries and
caucuses Iowa and New Hampshire but
Bernie Sanders is not willing winning
the delegate math and that is firing up
many many people
Andrew yang did drop out yesterday after
an abysmal 2.8 percent in New Hampshire
we're going to talk about that a little
later but now we go on to a presidential
debate next Wednesday that'll be
followed by voting in the Nevada
caucuses on Saturday February 22nd then
voting in South Carolina on Saturday
February 29th and then on to Super
Tuesday March 3rd which I believe will
really give us a sense of is the
trajectory continuing to look like a
contested convention are there really
two contenders right now it's Bernie and
Pete but you've got a bunch of people
that are still relatively close just a
few delegates separating everybody let's
look at those upcoming primaries and
caucuses we really don't know what the
hell is going on and you have in Nevada
because the last poll is a month old at
that point Biden was plus one over
Bernie that was a month ago
anything could happen in Nevada would
love to see some new polling there
south carolina has been widely expected
and assumed to go to joe biden for a
while now the latest poll is ten days
old and it has biden plus 18
I do believe South Carolina is
essentially a must-win for Biden now
realistically Biden will stay in at
least until Super Tuesday because
anything could happen on Super Tuesday
but Biden is not going to do well on
Super Tuesday unless he can gain
momentum by securing the win in South
Carolina that he has long been expected
to get if he doesn't get South Carolina
the Biden path starts to narrow even
more than it has already narrowed not to
mention that Elizabeth Warren has to
start picking up delegates she's polling
fourth in South Carolina I wouldn't be
surprised to see her end up with zero in
South Carolina remember that like with
most primaries there's this 15%
viability threshold in South Carolina if
you don't get 15% you get 0 delegates
right now Warren is polling eighth in
South Carolina not looking good so there
are now in reaction to yesterday's
Bernie win over Budaj edge there are all
sorts of hot takes about what does New
Hampshire mean for Bernie what does it
mean for the nomination and the reality
is that you can spin this almost any way
you want and a lot of people are so
let's go through now later we'll talk
about yang getting out and who else
should get out let's now talk about the
hot takes being floated around under the
guise of being enlightened think pieces